Violet Jessop, “Miss Unsinkable”, enjoyed
incredible “luck” from a
young age.
Born in 1887 in Argentina to Irish immigrants,
she contracted tuberculosis as a young child
and was given just a few months to live.
Somehow, she managed to fight the disease
and went on to live a long, healthy life.
When her father passed away, her mother moved
the family to Britain, where she took a job
as a stewardess on a ship.
While her mother was working, Violet attended
a convent school.
Unfortunately, her mother became ill, and
to provide for her siblings Violet decided
to follow in her mother’s footsteps and
become a ship stewardess herself.
The first in a long line of struggles for
Violet was finding a ship that would take
her.
She was just 21 years old at the time and
most women working as stewardesses in the
early 1900s were middle-aged.
Employers believed that her youth and good
looks would be a disadvantage to her, “causing
problems” with the crew and passengers.
(Over the course of her career, she did get
at least three marriage proposals while working
on various ships, one from an incredibly wealthy
first-class passenger.)
Eventually, Violet solved the issue by making
herself look frumpy with old clothes and no
make-up, and experienced more successful interviews
after this.
After a brief stint aboard the Orinoco, a
Royal Mail Line steamer, in 1908, she was
hired by the White Star Line.
Violet started out on the line’s Magestic,
switching to the Olympic in 1910.
Despite the long hours and minimal pay (£2.10
every month or about £200 today), she enjoyed
working aboard the massive ship.
She had initially had some concerns about
the rough weather conditions while traveling
across the Atlantic, but she reportedly liked
that the Americans treated her more like a
person while she served them.
It was just one year later when the trouble
started.
In 1911, the Olympic collided with the HMS
Hawke (a ship designed to sink ships by ramming
them).
Both ships sustained considerable damage,
including the Olympic having its hull breached
below the water line, but miraculously didn’t
sink.
They were able to make it back to port, and
Violet disembarked without being harmed.
A couple of years later, the White Star Line
was looking for crew to cater to the VIPs
aboard the unsinkable ship, the Titanic.
It took a while for her friends and family
to convince her that it would be a wonderful
experience, but Violet eventually decided
to take a job on board the ship.
As you already know, the Titanic struck an
iceberg and sunk, killing more than 1500 people.
Violet was able to escape the disaster on
lifeboat 16.
In her memoir, she recalls,
“I was ordered up on deck.
Calmly, passengers strolled about.
I stood at the bulkhead with the other stewardesses,
watching the women cling to their husbands
before being put into the boats with their
children.
Sometime after, a ship’s officer ordered
us into the boat first to show some women
it was safe.”
As she was jumping into the lifeboat, she
was handed a baby to care for.
When they were rescued by the Carpathia, the
baby’s mother (or at least Jessop thought
it must be) found her and whisked the baby
away (literally grabbing the baby out of Jessop’s
arms and running off).
Once again, Violet lived to sail another day.
Although, she did later state the first thing
she missed after the Titanic sank was her
toothbrush that she’d left on board.
You’d think she’d stop getting on ships
at this point, or at least ships of the Olympic
class, but not Violet.
In the lead-up to World War I, she decided
to serve as a nurse on board the Titanic’s
other sister ship, Britannic, which was operating
in the Aegean Sea.
Given her track record, you can probably guess
what happened next.
The Britannic ran into a mine that had been
planted by a German U-boat.
The ship sustained substantial damage and
quickly started sinking.
This time, Violet wasn’t lucky enough to
jump into a lifeboat as the ship was sinking
too fast.
Instead, she jumped overboard.
In her own words,
“I leapt into the water but was sucked under
the ship’s keel which struck my head.
I escaped, but years later when I went to
my doctor because of a lot of headaches, he
discovered I had once sustained a fracture
of the skull!”
She joked that she only survived because of
her thick hair, which cushioned the blow.
She also stated this time she remembered to
grab her toothbrush before evacuating, unlike
with the Titanic.
Even this latest disaster was not enough to
deter Violet.
After the war, ships were becoming a more
and more popular form of transport.
Even cruise ships were starting to emerge.
Violet left the White Star Line for the Red
Star Line and worked on a ship doing world
cruises for several years.
Luckily for Violet and everyone traveling
on the ships she was aboard later, no such
vessel she worked on ever sustained significant
damage again.
She did take a clerical job for a while after
World War II, but went back to working on
Royal Mail ships for a few years before she
retired at the age of 61.
So after surviving the sinking of the sister
ships the Titanic and the Britannic, as well
as being aboard the third of the trio of Olympic
class vessels, the Olympic, when it had a
major accident, she ultimately died in 1971
of congestive heart failure at the ripe old
age
of 84.
•